hello Brian right there I'm sorry mm-hmm
Sally's gonna be watching a few trailers
on me by the way Luke it's a yeah so get
ready for a Sally and Ryan trailer
thought nah that's a good way to put it
I've been doing school so I've been busy
and not able to do things everyone knows
school doesn't really matter you're all
gonna end up [ __ ] anyway that's just
the truth
beg to differ I encourage you to still
go to college though I'm gonna get a
business degree
yes that's what people mainly advanced
with him I've been waiting for this all
week I had such a crappy week so let's
do this that's how exciting her life is
all week she's been looking forward to
watching a trailer I know you feel there
are some great trailers out there she
doesn't know this yet but we're gonna
watch the trailer for the new Godzilla
trailer the extended trailer that
everyone's talking about that bryan
cranston in it I hope so and I just love
Godzilla like I said well actually
figured I was younger and I'd bring it
in the pool with me and I'd be like crap
and all of you wanted me to watch it now
about a hot chick on the show let's do
this thank you is it all right let's
make this solution okay Sandra there the
doors open my wife is doing how scary
oh no oh yeah oh that's sad that's why
you was trying to get her so quickly you
know I did it you just met in the
background illumination uh-huh you had
to say people it was not a natural
disaster all right what's really
happening is that you're hiding
something out there go so it takes a
crowd to Jurassic Park all right no wow
he's gonna give a great [ __ ]
performance damn okay please shake it
together so she looks here a tall ship
again written actors
the dog notice is the water
it's a fast
damn dude I still I am oh the tension in
this movies it's incredible
let's go up how terrifying that it's so
scary
Oh chill is all over me I know many of
you have family did one still in the
city she's so pretty want to help well
this is your chance
dude this bird is going to be epic you
have no idea what's coming
it is going to send us back to the Stone
Age Oh
day looks so scary
you got a pretty clear shot of him in
that one is a Dan that was a good
[ __ ] trailer now I know what they're
gonna do at Universal the theme park oh
yeah yeah we gonna be like some sick
Godzilla riding yeah be cool if you blew
fire at you yeah oh wait all over I
thought he blew fire isn't he like I
don't want to say cuz I'm gonna hate on
me forgetting you're wrong yeah I don't
know what he is but dude I got you know
what I love the Bryan Cranston character
you know like something that you don't
think about when you think of the
Godzilla movie is like what are the main
characters gonna be like and in the main
character is a great I was already so
excited they were redoing a Godzilla
movie with like the technology we have
now and then when I found out prank
rants it wasn't this ugly it's done this
yeah like the best movie ever made like
he needs it's a great character set up
to you know like he had to let his wife
die unfortunately I'm seeing it the
first chance I get ya know I'm going to
IMAX so if you're new to the channel and
if you like hanging out with Sally and I
and I'm sweating right now again every
time I'm next to sally I start sweating
subscribe yes and check out my channel
because I do weird stupid videos with
him and just with myself yeah he does
weird videos with her it is nobody know
the image you plant in people's minds
when you say that oh and it's subscriber
shoutout time but she Richard Patrick
this dude has his own YouTube channel
you sent me a comment saying I
encouraged him naturally to just make
his own videos more that was like thank
you Richard Patrick that's very kind of
you
so here shoutout yeah director Patrick a
drink did that
yo yay that I got Richard Patrick you
probably got a big dick and I come here
and that dick goes down my throat is
gonna make me sick are you gonna go
somewhere with that kind I'm gonna look
at he looks about sucking dick natasha
romanoff she leaves a lot of comments
I'm hoping your or she otherwise good
for you man do you thank you for
supporting the channel I really
appreciate everything you do so stay
sexy Sally we got a welcome in you
subscriber to the channel the dark
horrid own age 64 dark
lukkage 154 yeah zharko kids 154 yes
right Darko kitsch thank you for letting
me shout out to you because right now I
can feel Sally's right boob up against
my erect left arm and it is an awesome
feeling Thank You Sally thank you thank
you for molesting my arm no watch damn
it so what happens whenever I open my
mouth